how's it going everybody it's Warren I
hope everybody had and is still having a
good holiday season today we have some
news about the villain that everybody
wants to enter the MCU Victor Von Doom
aka Doctor Doom it's been reported and
rumored for some time now that Doctor
Doom is going to be one of the next big
bad villains of the MCU and recently
we've been getting more specific reports
about just what he's going to be doing
when he enters the MCU and now we have
even more evidence that says Victor Von
Doom is going to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe very soon Before we
jump into it don't forget to subscribe
when notifications turned on like the
video and leave a comment so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 I'm choosing a winner
at five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers now all of these reports
that we've gotten about Doctor Doom
entering the MCU have all come from
pretty credible people one of the first
ones came from Mikey Sutton who simply
stated that Doctor Doom is going to be
one of the main villains of the future
phases of the MCU then MCU cosmic came
out with a report stating that Doctor
Doom will be entering the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but it could be
through a Disney Plus show now all of
the Disney Plus Marvel shows are in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so this still
makes sense and a Kevin Feige has
already mentioned that just because a
character gets his own Disney Plus show
doesn't mean he won't end up in the
movies but then recent reports come from
Charles Murphy
Charles has recently stated that Doctor
Doom is going to be the villain of black
panther 2 and that Doctor Doom is going
to be seeking out vibranium in Wakanda
and recently it's been reported that
Doctor Doom could be the mysterious
benefactor that was talked about an
ant-man and the wasp and that he could
end up in the next ant-man movie as well
so a lot of talk and a lot of hype
around Doctor Doom lately and today we
have even more evidence that suggests he
may be introduced as early on as the one
vision series in phase 4 because today
we have another report from Charles
Murphy and seemingly some evidence that
says that dr. Doom's mother Cynthia Von
Doom could appear in the Wanda vision
Disney Plus show it's looking like the
one division series is really going to
have just about everything in it and
it's also looking like it's going to be
about the Scarlet Witch
learning how to actually use magic and
it's looking like one of the characters
that could tie into the Scarlet Witch
learning magic is victor von dooms
mother Cynthia Von Doom herself and it
looks like they're going to be bringing
Cynthia von doom and dr. Strange's
birthplace into the won Division Series
last night it was reported by Charles
Murphy that an actress confirmed that
she is going to be in the one division
series
she then tweeted out doom stat in Helen
so what exactly does this mean well for
those big Doctor Doom fans out there and
for those comic book fans out there as
well doom stat is the capital city of
Latveria and Latveria is the birthplace
of Victor Von Doom and is where his
mother is from now the small quaint town
of helen georgia is set to double for
doom stat
meaning that if dr. doom and doom stat
are going to be in the one division
series they're going to use Helen
Georgia to film at doom stat because it
looks very similar to what they want now
according to Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios the one division
series is set to be the craziest thing
that Marvel Studios has ever done and
it's certainly shaping out that way but
why bring Victor Von Doom into the Wan
division series
well again like I stated it's because of
his mother Cynthia Von Doom Cynthia Von
Doom is actually a very powerful Romania
sorceress with quite an interesting
backstory and we know thanks to some
leaked photos for the one division
series that it's going to explore Agatha
Harkness and her background and the
Salem witch trials so while they're
going to explore the sorceress Agatha
Harkness it seems like they're going to
explore the sorceress Cynthia Von Doom
as well and with that would come doctor
dooms origin story now the story of
Cynthia von doom and her son Victor Von
Doom is actually kind of sad
Cynthia Von Doom first appeared in
astonishing tales number 8 when a group
of Romania sorceress is that we're
living in Latveria came together and
formed the Saphira
Cynthia was trained in sorcery by elet
Varian mystic and would later go on to
marry Werner von doom and this is where
the story gets really interesting and
kind of crazy
eventually Cynthia would go on to get
imprisoned in a tower by a character
called the Baron and the prison was
overrun by vampires decades into the
future her son her future son dr. doom
learned about his mother's history dr.
doom Vincent
laid back in time to fight off all the
vampires and free his mother blade goes
back in time and teams up with Lucas
cross and the two of them work together
to fight off all the vampires and
afterwards Cynthia escapes so her future
son dr. doom in the future saves her at
this point in time she hadn't had him
yet so the future dr. doom saved his
mother and of course eventually Cynthia
goes on to have victor von doom Cynthia
would go on to lead this fire up for
some time and then one day she summons
Mephisto now for those of you who are
not familiar with Mephisto he's one of
the strongest Marvel villains ever and
he's basically the devil he's a demon he
was created by the Supreme Being who
suicide resulted in the creation of the
Marvel Universe as well as the infinity
gems so Cynthia summons Mephisto she
makes a deal with him in exchange for
the power to give her people a deserving
homeland she made a deal with mephesto
unaware of what was actually going to
happen and she stormed the Barons Tower
and told his guards that he had until
sunrise to leave the guards mocked her
and she ended up firing some energy
bolts at some of them killing them she
realized that she had no control over
the power that Mephisto gave her and
just as one of the guards was about to
die they stabbed her and severely
wounded her so she fled into the woods
and her husband Werner eventually found
her where she told him everything that
happened including her deal with
Mephisto sadly she went on to die and
not her funeral the other gypsies told
Warner to take Victor his son and flee
before the Baron found out so Warner led
the Sapphira and told them to leave at
dawn
Cynthia had a trunk of Arcade that was
filled with potions and secrets of magic
and Warner tried to get rid of it by
dumping it into the river but it
reappeared in his wagon three days later
due to Cynthia dying unconfessed Cynthia
was cursed to an eternity of damnation
by Mephisto eventually a young dr. doom
would discover his mother's trunk and
discover all of the magical artifacts
inside of it this of course sparked his
interest and made him want to learn more
Victor Von Doom would eventually go on
to create what is called a necrophos and
used it to contact his mother he saw
that she was being tortured by Mephisto
over the years of Victor Von Doom
studied and learned magic until he
eventually summoned Mephisto and
challenged him to a duel for his
mother's soul every midsummer evening
dr. doom would
spell that summoned demons to fight and
each time he fought them he lost dr.
doom tried everything that he could to
defeat my festos demons to try and get
his mother back he went on to partner
with Morgan la Fey to gain magical
abilities and he even went on to kidnap
Franklin Richards and offer him to
Mephisto in exchange for his mother's
soul and for those of you who do not
know Franklin Richards is the son of mr.
fantastic and The Invisible Woman of the
Fantastic Four and is one of the
strongest mutants ever things with the
deal ended up going wrong and Mephisto
ended up getting his hands on Franklin
Richards
although Franklin Richards was too
strong Summa Fisto banished him back to
earth dr. doom would go on to enter a
vishanti contest in which he placed
second and his prize was that he was
given a boon with dr. strange he made a
request with dr. strange asking him to
take him to hell so he could confront
mephesto once he got there however he
betrayed dr. strange offering his soul
in exchange for his mother's Mephisto
restored Cynthia's body when he got his
hands on dr. strange but as soon as she
found out what dr. doom did in order to
get her soul back she turned to stone
Mephisto would get his hands on the
souls of dr. doom dr. strange and dr.
Doom's mother synthia but dr. doom
brought a device with him that shattered
Mephisto's crystal releasing the three
of them the three of them then attacked
Mephisto but their powers were nothing
compared to his Buffy stow mocks them
but Cynthia decides that she doesn't
want to leave hell based on the pact
that dr. doom made sacrificing dr.
Strange's soul Cynthia ends up going
through the redemption process enough to
purify her soul and Mephisto cannot
tolerate it so he allows her to ascend
to a higher plane to where she would no
longer be tortured but Fisto also allows
dr. strange and dr. doom to return to
Earth in this higher plane Cynthia has a
cauldron to where she can watch what
happens with dr. doom her son on earth
so as you can see it's kind of a crazy
story and dr. doom really does
everything that he can to try and get
his mother back but this all ties into
the one division series and the setup
for the future of them so you very well
again we know from the leaked photos
that we have from the one division
series that they're going to explore
Agatha Harkness plus they're going to
explore other witches and the Salem
witch trials so it really is a very nice
segue to explore Cynthia von doom and
then there's the time travel and blade
aspect of
well after Avengers in-game time travel
is now a part of the MCU and they're
most likely going to explore this in
future films in the MCU and they can
even do basically a reiteration of what
happens in the comics in the series a
future Victor Von Doom could send blade
who we know is going to be entering the
MCU pretty soon to rescue his mother so
not only could the one division series
give us the origin story for Victor Von
Doom but it could also introduce blade
as well and it makes a lot of sense that
they would try and introduce dr. doom as
early on in phase 4 as possible because
one thing that Marvel has kind of had a
problem with in the MCU is their
villains they did a great job with a
nose and that's because they built him
up over ten years however we didn't get
too much of a back story about Thanos
they gave us a little bit of a backstory
in Avengers infinity war but having us
go through what the villain is going
through all throughout the years and
watching him become this big bad villain
is something that the fans have wanted
for a very long time and when you have
such a huge villain like Doctor Doom who
goes on to eventually become God Emperor
Doom in Avengers secret Wars battle
world you want to see him build up we
want to go on the journey with him so
this just makes a ton of sense watching
the origin of Doctor Doom seeing him in
Black Panther 2 seeing him in ant-man 3
and other films as he's built up to
become this huge villain I think this is
the right way to go but let me know what
you all think do you like the idea of
the one division series exploring the
origin of Doctor Doom and his mother and
would you like to see Doctor Doom
throughout multiple MCU films until he
eventually goes on to become the big bad
leave your thoughts down below also
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe but with notifications turned
on so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
I picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers also don't
forget only 5 days left and the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway so be sure to click
the link in the description down below
to enter as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof